china's deadliest aviation disaster in
decades could have been deliberate a
media report citing u.s officials says
the march crash of china eastern flight
mu5735
could have been caused by court someone
in the cockpit u.s officials are helping
analyze the flight's data recorder and
cockpit voice recorder
the new assessment is based on
information from this data
132 people lost their lives after the
boeing 737-800
plunged vertically into a mountainside
in southern china
this video unverified but widely shared
on social media allegedly shows the
final moments of flight mu5735
on march 21st
soon afterward crews began retrieving
the debris each piece a potential clue
into what caused the deadly disaster
now there are indications that the crash
might have been deliberate
data from the black box reportedly shows
someone had sent a plane into a fatal
nosedive
this according to the wall street
journal which cited people familiar with
the preliminary assessment of u.s
officials
the u.s took part in the investigation
since the aircraft was manufactured
there
the boeing
737-800 from china eastern airline was
on its way to the southern city of
guangzhou when it suddenly plunged into
a mountainside
none of the 132 people on board survived
both the u.s and china say they've
received no information from the other
side on their respective investigation
results so far
although beijing says it's doing its
part to share data and will keep doing
so
aviation regulators will continue to
maintain close communication with all
parties involved in the investigation
and release related information in a
timely and accurate manner
china eastern airline had previously
said the pilot's health and family
conditions were good
when asked about a possible cockpit
intrusion it said such scenario was not
plausible
almost two months after the tragedy
families of the deceased say their
wounds will not heal
not at least until they know why it
happened
and joining me now for more from
melbourne is crystal jung she's an
associate professor at rmit university
australia and an expert in china's
aviation industry professor zhang
welcome what is your reaction to the
media report that this crash was
deliberate i mean could this be true
and thank you very much uh for having me
today it's my pleasure to be here my
first reaction is that
is very surprisingly pleasant in terms
of how speedy it is and to restore and
analyze the the data from the damaged
black boxes because as we know from the
previous reports and also from the
information available that the two black
boxes actually were severely damaged and
then they were transported to america
for data restoration and data analysis
so that really means it's less than two
months time the data was able to be
restored and to be analyzed and some
information apparently was available for
further investigation further analysis
so i think from that perspective it's
really very very effective in
investigation process but to what extent
that information is um you know i'm not
questioning the authentication of the
data but i think it's still a need for
the investigation that really
demonstrates there might be various
scenarios that the investigators are
very very interested and willing to
explore so it might be one of the
scenarios that they need to investigate
right now let's assume for a moment that
the final investigation and we're still
awaiting this final investigation that
this investigation concludes that this
was indeed a deliberate act do you think
we can expect china to make this report
public
um
so that is a kind of a proposition in
the event that it is a deliberate effect
i i'm um
i'm confident that uh the investigator
and also the authority caac as a
regulator and also safety investigation
authorization will be very
honest and and on the fact and but if
there are other contributing factors and
also as we know that when something
contributes to the air crash and perhaps
it is not just one single effect that
effect that will contribute to the uh
air crash perhaps there are more than
one contributing factors so that we need
to take a holistic and systematic
approach to that china has had a
relatively good safety record air safety
record in the past decade particularly i
mean can you talk to us a bit about the
standards
of air safety employed in china to make
sure that aircraft are safe to fly
yes absolutely i think as we know that
in the past 14 years perhaps china has
maintained a very high safety record in
terms of there is no fatal crash and the
latest one in besides this one was 1994
and that was the aircraft crashed in the
very northeastern city in china
but
ever since then there apparently there
has been no fatal crash but having said
that apparently there are
some issues in terms of the safety
hazard et cetera et cetera and this is
something that is not
not not avoidable in aviation are
operated because we know that the air
transport industry is a high risk
industry and the safety is the priority
of the industry at the global scale and
so china apparently is very committed to
enhancing its safety management system
and implemented various type of
procedures and
measurements in terms of improving a
safety record
but having said that we do understand
that in the past 10 decade in the past
10 years in the past decade that the air
transport has been
growing very very rapidly exponentially
in china's domestic market and the
chinese authority they recognize that
there are variations in terms of the
development and the growth of the air
transport industry for example the
eastern
airports along the eastern coast
so that is rapidly developing but um you
know the central and the western part is
also experiencing rapid growth
but then the traffic is really shifting
from the east to the west but in terms
of the infrastructure et cetera et
cetera western and the central parts of
china is not as advanced or as to the
extent as those in the in the eastern
part so that actually um you know uh
gives a significant kind of a pressure
in terms of the safety management so
from the industry's perspective
apparently you know this kind of
attention has been existing for quite
some time
either you are satisfying the air travel
demand you know from the public or you
maintain the very high safety record
so
the industry department has been very
committed to maintaining the very high
safety record but apparently something
has happened very recently
we'll have to leave it there for the
time being but thank you so much for
that insight into china's aviation
industry crystal jang from the rmit
university in australia thank you so
much
my pleasure thank you